Israeli Prime Minister Benjamin
Netanyahu says a compromise on his
controversial judicial reforms could be
possible the proposals have sparked the
biggest protests in the nation's history
critics fear the changes will harm the
independence of the Judiciary
U.S President Joe Biden is urging
Netanyahu to abandon the plan but
Netanyahu says Israel won't bow to
International pressure but he's denied
any Rift between Israel and Washington
Israel and the United States have had
their occasional differences but I want
to assure you that the alliance between
the world's greatest democracy
and a strong proud and independent
democracy Israel in the heart of the
Middle East
is unshakable nothing can change that
well senior political analyst Marlon
bashara says Netanyahu didn't expect
President Biden to tell him to drop his
judicial overhaul uh it shocked
Netanyahu himself he didn't he didn't
see it coming as it were I think he was
too arrogant and believed that his
relationship with Biden is so uh close
that uh the American president wouldn't
do that to him but there's a gathering
storm in Washington and in America in
general not just because the
administration is upset with the fact
that Netanyahu is doing what Netanyahu
was doing along with a whole number of
Fanatics and fascists in his coalition
government but because the American
Jewish leadership doesn't like what's
happening in Israel they don't like this
fanatic Ultra Orthodox Coalition in
Israel that doesn't even recognize
Reform Judaism conservative conservative
Judaism that makes the majority of
American Jews they don't recognize them
as Jewish so American Jewish Community
is quite upset and now Biden is upset
and so there's the rebuke of the Israeli
government what he's trying to do is to
get a legislative where it sidelines
Supreme Court and limits the power of
the Judiciary so that he and his cronies
can legislate any law of any kind that
basically will keep him on top and keep
him more like an autocrat than a
Democrat